okay guys i just got up here i had to
run up here i'm really disappointed
no one told me about this and i don't
know how this escaped
my attention i can't believe none of you
at all
told me about this what in the [ __ ] did
you not tell me about lady dimitrescu
okay i didn't see the resident evil news
i didn't see anything about it
apparently there's another game coming
out i've been kind of out of the loop
writing
and you didn't tell me about this
[Music]
no one told me about eight feet tall are
you kidding me eight
what the [ __ ] i'm not one for
objectifying okay
it's a video game character i think we
can all have a little bit dude
jesus christ okay i like i've
how many times have i said i want a
woman that could crush
my head in between her thighs any part
of her body could crush
my head and i know the part that you're
thinking of and that's just one
of several options and jesus [ __ ]
look at her what the hell no one told me
i had to find out about this literally
like two minutes ago amy told me about
this
and i was just like googling the
internet i was looking at like game
stops more like stop
look at this game and look at her what
the hell
what t-virus went into making that
because that's unbelievable look i'm not
i i'm listen okay all right you don't
need to back up a second because i
feel like it's getting a little manic
but i'm more just offend look at this
guy
hi so it runs in the family
anyway so oh my god look she got freddy
krueger hands
i literally don't just do this [ __ ]
make videos about one thing but it is
just so outrageous that no one thought
that i
was
no no one saw it no one thought no one
no one saw this and thought to inform me
of this
what is wrong with you how low do you
think of me how high do you think of me
i don't know what direction do you think
of me that would cause
you
look amy i'm sorry i have to i have to
get all this out or else it's gonna
fester inside of me and explode
oh my god so i have not even seen her
in motion i okay well
let's just i i'm gonna i'm gonna just
load resident evil village that's the
i didn't even know the name of the game
i don't even care i have to play this i
absolutely ha announcement trailer this
is probably it
what is this what is happening i uh look
i'm in a
tizzy you need to hush and uh who i
guess get out of
away go away no this ah third trailer
here we go
this is the one not that one whatever
that one was who cares hey now
think positively all right
we talked about this who are you you're
not who i'm looking for
we hardly talk about anything where's
lady demitricus if there's one thing
said her said her voice sir look i'm i'm
all for struggle
i'm all for strong strong
characters male or female but you gotta
understand
something primal i regret to inform you
that ethan winters has
escaped that fool heisenberg
because he is in my castle and has
already proven too much for my daughters
to handle
when i find him
no mother miranda yes
of course who's her mom of the ceremony
i won't let you down
don't let me down good god jesus christ
place is full of nothing but blood and
death yeah blood and death
that's not her that's not her
that's not her ah it's not her
not her hahahahaha
do i have to go back i gotta go back i
care about a baby i'll figure it out
when i play
yeah damn it yeah
there you are gotta make bigger doors
yeah whatever get out of here got my
face oh my god oh it's eight
yeah listen
i am a changed man from now on until
forever the end of the [ __ ] are you
who are you let's see all right whatever
man you know
you uh i i gotta go back because i
alright let's put speed at 2.5
there she okay all right
it's perfect smile you know you can tell
that personality really
shines why did no one tell me about this
i'm going to be thinking about this
literally
all the way until the game comes out and
then
there's going to be multiple episodes of
my playthrough that are just dedicated
to
the scenes with her wow
don't zoom in don't zoom in what are you
doing don't zoom in
i need all the picture i need it all
i've lost faith in you
for trying to hide this from me maybe
you knew maybe you knew
and if you did know what the hell okay
what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
you
it's not a sexual thing i don't want
anyone to think that it's not what it's
about it's not anything like that
god give me [ __ ] perverts is that
what you think is about it's not
it's about power it's not about pleasure
it's about power
my god look at the power my god the
power now all these don't even capture
the right imagine oh you're focused just
on the boobs
josh stop it get away you can't
truly encapsulate everything that i see
i said shut up my mom's calling me shut
mom not right now
i can't talk okay anyway
yeah okay all right i'm good i'm gonna
go now but shame on you
and shame on me
uh bye